you played such a great game how are you
feeling after your eviction what are
your emotions
well thank you for the compliment um i
haven't made up my mind yet if i think i
actually played a good game or not um
i am disappointed you know it's really
easy to look back at things now that i'm
evicted and i have more information and
think oh this is stupid and this was
stupid and i should have done that but i
know that in the moment i was making the
best decisions with the information that
i had i know i went as hard as i could
in the competitions that i did play
and um you know
i think i got as far as i could and i
just have to be okay with that
was the game harder than you thought
most people think it would be easy until
they're on the show
what would you have played differently
about your game
big brother is definitely way harder of
a game than i thought it was going to be
coming into it
um i
i think that um there were some things
that i really wanted to do that i was
not able to do when i was actually there
in the moment um i definitely you know
when i made the final two with kyle and
on day two i wanted to keep that under
wraps but pretty much the second that i
had a really stressful week and was on
the block in week five i was not able to
do that because i felt very alone and i
needed that comfort that i usually get
in the outside world um in that super
stressful environment and so instead of
continuing to hide how close me and kyle
were it just became super obvious and
that was something that i could never
recover from
um and that i didn't expect going into
the game how hard it would be to like um
to be by yourself and be playing a game
by yourself um
and uh
i think just keeping up the social
relationships too um i've always been a
social person so i didn't think it would
be hard for me but something that i know
now looking back at the game that i did
have days where i felt most comfortable
with kylan so i just wanted to hang out
with kailyn especially weeks where i
felt pretty safe or i knew that i wasn't
going to go on the block it was just
really easy to maybe take extra moments
to myself or just hang out with the
people that made me feel comfortable
because i was in such a stressful
environment and looking back on it i
know now that that wasn't the best
gameplay for me even when i was really
stressed and even if i didn't really
have to be working socially at that
moment i should have been to be making
people feel close and comfortable with
me and that might have allowed me to go
much further in this game and that's a
big regret that i have looking back on
it
kylan and aza's goodbye messages were
those comforting to you in a sense is
there someone in the house you'll miss
spending this time with the most
um
they were definitely comforting in a way
um i completely understand where both of
them are coming from i understand why
the secret alliance and
um the mission that aza mentioned would
be really important for them
and i support that and it is comforting
to know that kylian's not going to be
alone in this game and that he actually
does have better chances of winning than
i initially thought he would after i
left um because i am still rooting for
him
but also in a way it's a little
bittersweet because i really wanted to
win every decision i've made in this
game so far hasn't been just to last one
more week or two more weeks it's been to
get to a final two chair and win
and knowing what i know now it does seem
like the writing was already on the wall
for me and even if i had managed to make
it to a final two chair particularly
next to kailand i would have lost this
game and that's that's hard to swallow
but
um i do have a lot of respect for what
they're trying to do
and
that makes it much easier to deal with
who do you think will be leaving the
house next and why
um
now that i know that there is a secret
alliance um that kylan is in
kailyn had told me multiple times that
he think claire that he thinks claire
will leave next i'm guessing claire is
not in the secret alliance so i think he
may be correct and she might be the one
who leaves next she was the secret hoh
which means she had to throw this
competition so she's not even going to
be able to earn her safety um so she's
definitely in a dangerous
position at this point who do you want
to go far and who do you think will go
far in the game they are likely
different answers
they are different answers uh i'm still
rooting for kyland even though he
betrayed me and lied to me
um
i think he's an amazing person i think
he's an amazing player and i would love
to be able to cast my vote for him if he
makes it to a final two however i do
think xavier has the best chance right
now
i think xavier is probably also in the
secret alliance which means he has all
of those people looking out for him but
i also think he's got really good
relationships with everybody outside of
that alliance as well much better than
kylian does and so that's going to help
him go further than i think kylan can